В ефірі «heute journal» з
Гайнцом Вольфом та Марієттою Сломкою.
Доброго вечора! Мандрівники, котрі
подорожували на цих вихідних,
могли обрати пільговий квиток за 9 євро
від партії Зелених
або ж знижку на пальне від FDP.
Принаймні такий був розрахунок:
кожен отримує щось для своїх виборців,
адже ціновий діапазон для забезпечення цих рішень
приблизно однаковий:
2,5 і 3 млрд бюджету від платників податків.
Проте FDP зі своє пропозицією щодо пального
не отримала належного позитивного ефекту.
Трапилось те, про що попереджали економісти:
після зниження акцизів на пальне знижка для споживачів
не дійшла до власників авто за принципом 1:1.
Питання полягає у наступному:
як нафтові компанії використовують
зниження енергетичного податку.
Отож, FDP вимагає дій від міністра економіки Габека.
Сьогодні Роберт Габек
виступив з пропозицією, яка вразила багатьох.
Детальніше - Ян Фріче.
На тлі останніх подій, вони - як «найкращі вороги».
Міністр фінансів Крістіан Лінднер, котрий
просунув пропозицію знижки на пальне,
і міністр економіки Роберт Габек,
який з точки зору лібералів FDP має гарантувати,
що знижку відчують споживачі.
Сьогодні Роберт Габек розповів про свої плани.
На тому, що впроваджувалося як підтримка
для громадян і споживачів
тепер наживаються великі нафтові концерни.
Цілком зрозуміло, що так не має бути
і що це спричинює загальне невдоволення й обурення.
Тому Габек планує посилити
антимонопольне законодавство:
навіть якщо немає прямих доказів «картельної змови»,
антимонопольний комітет може
вживати жорстких заходів,
наприклад, конфіскувати прибутки концерну або
в крайньому разі навіть ліквідувати компанії.
Замість цього Габек також припускає можливість
впровадження податку на надприбуток.
Ви чудово знаєте про дискусії щодо
отримання надприбутків нафтовими концернами.
Звісно, все йде через податкове законодавство.
Але зараз можливість оподаткувати
надприбуток блокується.
Блокується передусім партією Лінднера.
Під час інтерв'ю у студії «ZDF» лідер FDP Крістіан Лінднер
рішуче відкидає податок на надприбуток.
Сподіваюся, пропозиція щодо
цього «податку на надприбуток»
вже не розглядається,
адже це рішення спричинило б
хаос у податковому законодавстві,
а також хиткість політичних настроїв.
Загальнонімецький автомобільний клуб ADAC
схвалює ініціативу Габека.
Замість обіцяної знижки
у розмірі 35 центів на бензин
і 17 центів на дизель
водіям пропонують набагато менше.
На бензин діє знижка приблизно 20 центів
порівняно з ціною до зниження податків.
На дизель знижки ще менші - всього 5 центів.
Тож споживачі не отримують повноцінної знижки.
Габек також підкреслює,
що з початку місяця спостерігається
велика різниця між закупівельними цінами на нафту та
цінами на пальне на АЗС.
Нафтова Асоціація не вбачає своєї провини.
Ефект від зниження енергетичного податку
передається власникам авто.
Але попри зниження енергетичного податку
на бензин і дизель,
ціни на паливо зросли в усьому світі.
І не тільки тут, у Німеччині.
Плани міністра критикує й опозиція.
Втручання антимонопольного комітету
у випадку, коли не зафіксовано жодних порушень,
буде неможливим з перспективи закону.
Пропозиція Габека не спричинить
негайного зниження цін для споживачів.
Дійсно, плани Габека навряд чи призведуть
до швидкого зниження цін на АЗС.
Міністр економіки сподівається реалізувати
своє рішення ще цього року.
Останнє слово щодо знижки на пальне ще не сказане.
Напруження в «світлофорній» коаліції зберігається.
Якщо канцлер Німеччини Олаф Шольц
та президент Франції Еммануель Макрон
таки вирушатимуть до Києва,
то оберуть, очевидно, найпопулярніший вид транспорту,
яким прибували до Києва і інші очільники держав та урядів країн:
залізницю.
Варіантів мало: офіційного авіасполучення немає,
а поїздка на автомобілі небезпечніша,
вже не кажучи про розбиті дороги.
Українська залізниця - життєво важлива для країни:
20 000-кілометрова мережа залізниці з'єднує
великі міста і крихітні села,
внутрішні території і узбережжя.
Без залізниці Україна була б ізольована:
люди не могли б виїхати,
а зброя не змогла б потрапити до країни.
Той факт, що поїзди продовжують курсувати,
вже давно став вирішальними для війни,
і персонал залізниці бореться за це
так відважно, як солдати на фронті.
Крістіан Зіверс зустрівся в Києві з людиною,
яку в Україні сприймають як справжнього героя -
- очільником Укрзалізниці.
Крістіан і наш колега Дара Хасанзаде
цього тижня навідалися до України
і прибули зі Львова до Києва, звичайно, потягом.
На цих рейках тримається майбутнє усієї країни.
Хто їде у цьому потязі - усвідомлює ризики.
Допустима швидкість -  80 км/год,
хоча, незважаючи на свій вік,
потяг з легкістю подолає поділку в 130 км/год.
Вночі краще їхати без світла.
Російські ракети постійно тримають
залізницю під прицілом.
Українська залізниця від початку війни зазнала втрат:
майже 200 загиблих працівників.
Перевозимо людей з
небезпечних територій у безпечні,
також привозимо гуманітарну допомогу.
На сьогоднішній день - це дуже важливо.
Майже чверть залізничної мережі
вже зруйнована через війну.
Там, де потяги досі курсують, -
для українців це часто єдиний транспортний засіб.
Єдина можливість зустрітися із сім'єю та
друзями або ж поїхати на щотижневий ринок.
До Києва - ще 4 години.
А вже коли почалась війна
мені справді було страшно.
Ми їхали у поїзді, і не знали,
що може трапитися наступної хвилини.
Пасажири теж їдуть, кожен запитує:
«Чи все буде добре, чи ми доїдемо?»
Експорт пшениці - на Захід, зброю - на Схід.
Логістика залізниці вирішує долю.
Те, що відомо з минулих часів і книг по історії
знову актуально: залізнична війна.
В центрі цієї війни - величезне підприємство,
з якого дотепер більшість навіть підсміювалася.
5000 залізничних переїздів,
хтось у захисному жилеті і з жовтим прапорцем,
будівля для сторожа залізниці,
поруч навіть невеликий город.
Наша подорож розпочалася у Львові.
Порятунок для поранених
зі Сходу країни.
12 довгих годин цей спецпоїзд був у дорозі,
але це все одно швидше,
аніж на машині швидкої допомоги
по розбитих дорогах та ще й з дефіцитом пального.
Ми оглянули 5 пацієнтів інтенсивної терапії.
У чоловіка важка форма черепно-мозкової травми.
Зараз у нього дещо сплутана свідомість.
Ми відвеземо його до лікарні швидкої допомоги.
У нас є кисневі балони, апарати ШВЛ.
Взагалі потяг - це чудова ідея.
Місцеві люди, які допомагають, пишаються, що
можуть бути корисними там, де це потрібно.
Точна локація зупинки поїзда не розголошується.
Рятівники бояться, що
ті, у кого війна відняла майже все,
знову можуть стати мішенню російських атак.
Центральний вокзал Львова, перон номер 3,
одні їдуть на фронт захищати країну,
інші їдуть від війни.
Скільки ж історій приховує залізничий вокзал.
Все видається звичним
і важко усвідомити, що ж насправді відбувається.
Ця «нормальність» відчувається
якось по-особливому.
У цьому місті по справжньому не відчутно, що йде війна.
З усією жорстокістю і невимовним жахом.
Тут все так красиво.
Подивіться на це місто, всі виглядають щасливими,
але я знаю, що всі відчувають цей біль.
Сім'я Дергунових повертається додому.
Війна змусила їх виїхати в Чехію.
Але туга за домом сильніша.
Поки що наш будинок та
ті, що знаходяться поруч - цілі.
Але в селі є зруйновані будинки.
Наше село зараз розділене на дві частини:
стару і «нову», яка повністю знищена.
Крихта надії та море турбот.
Святику лише два роки, а він уже розуміє,
у якому стані перебуває його сім'я.
І відчуває, що він зараз розрада для них.
Уже два дні сім'я у дорозі.
Попереду ще 12 годин.
Потягом через усю Україну.
Ми приєднуємося до Крістіана Зіверса у Києві.
Привіт.
Ти в Києві від учора.
Які твої перші враження?
Дуже суперечливі...
З одного боку - особливо у таку погоду -
це літній мегаполіс,
який насолоджується життям,
і цим він нагадує Тель-Авів.
Життя в режимі «тут і зараз».
У вуличних кафе, барах, ресторанах багато людей.
В меню українська ф'южн-кухня
з неочікуваною «родзинкою».
Електросамокати припарковані акуратно в ряд
на узбіччі.
Є й інша сторона - люди помітно стурбовані.
Поліція відразу задає питання, коли бачить камеру.
Коли темніє і настає комендантська година,
ще й тривожні сирени на додачу,
місто стає порожнім і тихим,
виникає страх перед тим, що може статися.
У твоєму репортажі добре видно:
залізниця - це життєво важлива артерія країни,
а її керівник – практично національний герой.
Це абсолютно точно.
Але він не любить, коли його так називають,
хоча йому постійно про це говорять.
Він місяцями не був удома,
з міркувань безпеки
йому надано власний ﻿спальний вагон.
Кажуть, що на нього полюють російські спецслужби.
Він у їхньому списку.
Йому доводиться бути дуже обережним,
він керує однією з найбільших компаній країни,
яка має 230 000 співробітників.
Компанією, яка за одну ніч
стала найважливішою в Україні, і,
водночас, гордістю всього народу,
а також символом опору.
Я розмовляв із ним сьогодні, у бізнес-лаунжі
Центрального вокзалу «﻿Укрзалізниці» в Києві.
Отже, Олександре Камишін, дякую за те,
що Ви з нами.
Дякую за запрошення.
Вам 37 років, якщо я можу це озвучити.
На перший погляд, Ви не схожі
на типового очільника залізниці.
Ви керуєте, безумовно, найбільшою компанією України.
На момент, коли почалася війна,
Ви обіймали посаду 6 місяців.
Що Вам довелося змінити, щоб вистояти,
щоб пройти через це?
У перші дні війни потрібно швидко приймати рішення
та брати на себе відповідальність.
Потрібно швидко реагувати.
Протягом перших 100 днів потрібно
робити прогнози.
Слід встановити правила та розробити протоколи.
Зараз ми переживаємо наступні 100 днів війни,
і перед нами постають нові виклики.
Ми повинні передбачити, що відбудеться за рік,
і підготуватися відповідним чином.
Нам потрібно створити команду,
здатну відповідним чином реагувати
і управляти компанією в нових умовах.
В історії часто траплялося так,
що війни фактично вирішувалися тим,
яка сторона зрештою
мала найкращу залізничну логістику.
Чи вважаєте Ви, що і ця війна вирішуватиметься
на коліях?
Логістика, безперечно, важлива,
але я не хочу перебільшувати її значення.
Коли ми переможно завершимо цю війну,
ми всі зберемося і вирішимо, що було важливіше.
Звичайно, армія - на першому місці,
але дехто каже,
що залізниця - це друга армія.
Нас можна співставити у кількості співробітників,
і, звичайно, ми є важливими певною мірою.
Останнім часом багато політиків
покладаються на українську залізницю.
Наприклад, голова Комісії ЄС Урсула фон дер Ляєн,
американський міністр закордонних справ,
лідер німецької опозиції Фрідріх Мерц.
Усі вони подорожували залізницею.
З іншого боку, Ви змушені спробувати якось
компенсувати блокаду портів,
вивозити український експорт залізницею,
експорт зерна, наприклад, продовольства,
зерна для всього світу.
Яку підтримку Ви очікуєте від Заходу,
особливо від Німеччини?
Всі наші сусіди та партнери, включно з Німеччиною,
дуже допомагають нам.
Але ми потребуємо більшого.
Тому що - якщо говорити про зерно -
зараз ми експортуємо 1,2 млн тонн загалом,
включаючи логістику залізницею.
Але ми маємо експортувати 5 млн тонн,
тобто у чотири рази більше, і ще більше зерна
надійде з новим урожаєм.
Олександр Камишін, голова «Укрзалізниці».
Дякую за цю розмову.
Дуже дякую, що прийшли, Крістіане.
Цей нетиповий керівник на час війни
призначив команду управлінців із 6 осіб.
Вони мають керувати цією величезною корпорацією.
Він каже, що в ній працює троє молодих людей
щойно з бізнес-шкіл Сінгапуру та США.
А з іншого боку, троє залізничників
із загальним досвідом у 95 років.
Він каже, що буває так: коли потрібно «пройти крізь двері»,
приходить молодь та відразу «вибиває двері»,
а старші колеги спокійно кажуть
«ми вже знаємо, що за дверима».
Якщо їх об'єднати, каже очільник Укрзалізниці,
можна успішно керувати підприємством.
Він також вважає, що війна триватиме ще роки.
Він намагається підготувати до цього компанію,
свої сім'ю та себе.
Завтра у Крістіана буде ще більше цікавих
співрозмовників у Києві,
і тоді ми з Вами також проведемо частину
«heute journal» прямо з Києва.
До завтра!
Дякую, бувай!
А Росія?
Як бачать війну в Москві чи Санкт-Петербурзі,
по ту сторону вечірніх пропагандистських передач
на державному телебаченні?
Путін поки що утримується від загальної мобілізації,
під час якої може бути призваний кожен.
Більшість його солдатів досі були вихідцями з
Республіки Дагестан
на Північному Кавказі або з Середньоазійського
регіону біля озера Байкал.
Бідна сільська місцевість, далеко від Москви.
Наскільки війна та санкції
вже відчуваються у столиці?
Аксель Шторм з репортажем із Москви.
Коли піаніст Лука Сафронов у березні цього року
прикував себе до своєї улюбленої філії
McDonald's у Москві,
він був не просто голодним.
Сьогодні компанія McDonald's вирішила різко
покинути нас.
З якоїсь причини.
Інші теж хочуть піти від нас.
Ми завжди платили гарні гроші за обслуговування.
Гастрольна вистава Сафронова
виявилася недовгою.
Звісно, ​​його затримали.
Проте ера McDonald's все рівно добігає кінця.
Зміна способу життя через відмову
від жиру для фрітюру та гамбургерів провалилася.
Рузанна, навпаки, вірить, що сьогодні настав її час.
Вранці - відкриття нової московської філії.
Преса, камери, інтерв'ю, зголоднілі відвідувачі.
Ще один символ цієї події: все продовжується.
Російська версія бургерної тепер називається
без прикрас «Вкусно и точка».
Я дуже радію цьому відкриттю.
Я майже три місяці не спала,
мріючи про наше відкриття.
Зараз тут не так багатолюдно, як у січні 1990 року,
коли американський гігант швидкого харчування
відкрив свою першу філію в Москві.
І, звісно, ​​ні Міккі Маус, ні Гуфі сьогодні не танцювали.
Але московити хочуть їсти гамбургери та картоплю фрі.
І це цілком влаштовує можновладців.
Адже санкції поступово набирають чинності.
Ні новий ресторан швидкого харчування,
ні сьогоднішнє національне свято День Росії
не можуть приховати цього факту.
Ізоляція країни впливає на повсякденне життя людей.
Продукти харчування стали дорожчими.
Із пенсією в 20 000 рублів - близько 330 євро -
ви це відчуваєте.
Все стало дорожчим приблизно на 30%.
Раніше буханець хліба коштував 36 рублів,
сьогодні - 64 рублі.
Це не високі ціни, це дуже високі ціни.
Але мене це не засмучує, повірте.
Жити можна завжди.
Полиці супермаркетів, як і раніше, добре заповнені.
Але на поличках вже є російська версія «Coca-Cola» -
«CoolCola».
Нова ера, початок нової реальності,
яка стосується багатьох.
Ми дуже гостро відчуваємо санкції у медичному секторі.
«У нас закінчуються деякі матеріали.
Я це відчуваю щодня на роботі,
нам бракує інструментів і робочих матеріалів»
Як зміниться ситуація в майбутньому?
Поки що майбутнє туманне і похмуре.
Звичайно, ми всі сподіваємося на краще,
але чи справдяться наші очікування?
Прогнозувати ситуацію можемо наразі тільки
на кілька днів вперед.
Неможливість планувати, непрогнозованість, безмовність.
Військова «спецоперація» Путіна залишає глибокі сліди.
Також і в Росії.
Інформацію про війну і воєнні стратегії Кремля,
аналітику та причини
Ви знайдете онлайн на сторінці zdf.heute.
Гайнц продовжить тему.
Через зміну безпекової ситуації
Фінляндія та Швеція майже місяць тому
подали заявку на вступ до НАТО.
Проте Туреччина блокує процес.
Генсек НАТО Столтенберг заявив,
що розуміє стурбованість Туреччини.
Під час візиту до Фінляндії генсек заявив:
якщо член Альянсу
висловлює занепокоєння щодо тероризму,
то це потрібно сприймати серйозно та обговорювати.
Туреччина звинувачує Фінляндію і Швецію
в підтримці терористичних організацій.
Завтра Столтенберг прибуде з візитом до Швеції.
Активні дебати розпочалися після заяви
президента ФРН Штайнмаєр виданню «Bild am Sonntag»
про пропозицію запровадити обов'язкову соціальну службу
для всієї молоді.
Питання в тому, чи не піде на користь нашій країні те,
що жінки й чоловіки протягом певного часу
нестимуть соціальну службу.
Федеральна міністерка у справах сім'ї Паус
від партії Зелених
та міністерка освіти Старк-Ватцінгер з партії FDP
виступили проти впровадження «соціального обов'язку»,
не бажаючи порушувати право молоді
вільно приймати рішення.
Після ножового нападу
в Університеті прикладних наук Гамма-Ліпштадта
внаслідок отриманих травм
померла 30-річна жінка -
позаштатна викладачка університету.
Внаслідок нападу в пʼятницю
постраждало троє студентів.
34-річного підозрюваного
вчора відправили до психіатричної клініки.
Минуло близько 3 тижнів після
стрілянини в початковій школі Техасу.
Позапартійна група в Сенаті США узгодила пропозиції
для покращення захисту від вогнепального насильства.
Серед них - ретельніша перевірка
потенційних покупців зброї віком до 21 року.
Президент США Байден заявив,
що в пропозиціях не було всіх заходів,
які він вважає необхідними,
але Сенат рухається у правильному напрямку.
Наступний крок - ухвалення закону Конгресом США.
На тлі війни в Україні
та пандемії коронавірусу
у Женеві розпочалася конференція
міністрів Світової організації торгівлі.
164 країни-учасниці
обговорюватимуть зокрема питання
призупинення патенту на засоби проти коронавірусу.
Дискутуватимуть також про субсидії у галузі рибальства,
про сільське господарство і продовольчу безпеку.
У Франції стає цікавіше.
За попередніми розрахунками парламентських виборів
«макроністи» і опозиція мають
приблизно однаковий результат.
З одного боку - виборці Еммануеля Макрона,
з іншого - союз лівих сил
на чолі з політиком Жаном-Люком Меланшоном,
якому вдалося обʼєднати
роздроблених та розсварених лівих.
Чий результат виявиться кращим,
дізнаємося вже наступної неділі
після другого туру голосування.
З нами Томас Вальде з Парижа.
Для Еммануеля Макрона сьогодні, на перший погляд, не надто
вдалий виборчий день, чи не так?
Ми спостерігаємо таку ж тенденцію,
як під час першого туру президентських виборів.
Макрон переміг, проте з меншим відривом,
ніж 5 років тому.
Французи хочуть, щоб Макрон був при владі,
але голосують за нього
без такого великого ентузіазму, як раніше.
Тенденція зберігається і на парламентських виборах.
За попередніми результатами виборів до Національних зборів
абсолютна більшість блоку Макрона під загрозою.
Ймовірно, він зможе керувати і з відносною більшістю
у парламенті,
якщо знайде партнерів,
наприклад, серед консервативних республіканців
або демократичних соціалістів.
Але щоб це зробити, йому слід йти на компроміси частіше,
ніж дотепер.
У Німеччині дивуються тому,
що під час президентських виборів у квітні
найсильнішим конкурентом Макрона була
права популістка Ле Пен.
Але зараз вона не відіграє великої ролі?
Причина цього криється у французькому виборчому праві.
Відповідно до законів, у 577 виборчих округах
пройде лише один кандидат,
той, хто отримає більше голосів.
Тож перевагу матимуть ті, хто утворив союзи та
вів перемовини.
Що, власне, і зробив Меланшон, обʼєднавшись з іншими
партіями лівих, із соціалістами, комуністами та зеленими.
Тож вони, так би мовити,
розділили між собою політичну карту.
А оскільки Меланшон у першому раунді отримав найбільше
голосів серед його союзників,
то зараз керує союзом.
Інші ж вирішили бути тепер на його боці,
оскільки боялися взагалі втратити можливість
отримати місця в парламенті.
Томасе, дякую за інформацію.
А зараз Гайнц поділиться іншими новинами.
У Берліні десятки тисяч людей виїхали
на демонстраційний велозаїзд,
вимагаючи кращих умов для велосипедистів у столиці.
Демонстранти їздили по всьому Берліну.
Перекрили багато доріг, навіть центральну магістраль.
На думку учасників заїзду, така ініціатива спонукатиме
Сенат Берліну і райони вживати нових заходів.
Ініціатором демонстрації став
Загальнонімецький велоклуб ADFC.
У Формулі-1 Макс Ферстаппен виграв
Гран-прі Азербайджану.
У Баку голландець зайняв 1-ше місце
на 2-му - його товариш по команді «Ред булл» Серхіо Перес,
Джордж Рассел у «Мерседес» фінішував третім.
Ферстаппен здобуває п'яту перемогу у сезоні
та зберігає своє лідерство в чемпіонаті.
Кращий результат Німеччини:
Себастьян Феттель на 6-му місці.
Помер дворазовий футболіст року НДР і капітан збірної НДР -
Бернд Бранш.
Про це повідомив ФК «Галлешер».
За його словами, 77-річний чоловік помер
вчора після тривалої хвороби.
Бранш 72 рази грав за збірну НДР.
А у 1974 році на чемпіонаті світу був капітаном команди.
Через одинадцять днів стартують
змагання «Die Finals 2022» у 14 видах спорту.
У Берліні сьогодні відбулася пресконференція
з низкою найкращих спортсменів.
На кону - 190 титулів.
Змагання триватимуть з 23 по 26 червня.
Телеканали ARD і ZDF вестимуть трансляції.
Тривалість випусків становитиме більш ніж 25 годин.
А зараз короткий огляд подій наступного тижня.
Крістіан Руфус далі.
Скільки солдатів мають вийти на східний фланг НАТО
і чи повинні вони там залишатися?
Це питання, а також питання,
які країни НАТО постачатимуть зброю Україні,
обговорять у середу
міністри оборони країн НАТО.
На запрошення США відбудеться зустріч
так званої контактної групи України,
в складі якої 40 країн-партнерів.
Хто очолить AfD у майбутньому?
Під час партійного зʼїзду в місті Різа
свою кандидатуру висуне лідер партії Тіно Хрупала.
Ще невідомо, чи керуватиме він один,
чи спільно з колегою-лідеркою партії Аліс Вайдель.
Для цього AfD має змінити свій статут.
Свою кандидатуру висунуть заступник лідера партії
Норберт Кляйнвехтер
та депутат Європейського парламенту Ніколаус Фест.
Партія сподівається покращити результати
останніх виборів у федеральних землях
та до парламенту Німеччини.
Митці з усього світу представлять свої роботи
під час п'ятнадцятої виставки Documenta (15),
що розпочнеться цієї суботи в місті Кассель.
Цього разу куратором виставки став
колектив Ruangrupa з Індонезії.
Він виступає за сталий підхід до ресурсів й колективний поділ.
Наразі Documenta звинувачують в антисемітизмі,
адже організатори виставки не запросили
жодного митця з Ізраїлю.
А зараз до прогнозу погоди на новий тиждень.
Завтра на півночі та сході хмарно з проясненнями.
Очікуються дощі та грози.
На підніжжі Альп зранку вітряно та грози.
Подекуди сонячно.
Поривчастий північно-західний вітер.
Температура 16-25°.
У вівторок на півночі хмарно та сухо, 18-28°.
На півдні сонячно.
Надалі ставатиме все спекотніше до 32°.
Іронічно, та далі у програмі
серіал «Вбивство посеред літа».
О 00:30 в ефірі «heute Xpress».
А завтра ми знову зустрінемося тут з Майнца і з Києва.
До зустрічі!